-Welcome back, everybody.
It is time to settle some of the biggest
and most important food debates of all time.
But I'm gonna need some help.
His new show, "Next Level Chef,"
airs Wednesday at 9:00 p.m. on Fox.
Please welcome Gordon Ramsay, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's my man right there! Ah ha ha!
-Ahh. -Gordon Ramsay!
-Hello, mate. How are you? -I'm doing good, my friend.
Gordon, are you ready to do this?
-I am. I've got to give a quick hello from somebody.
I just want to -- Before he goes to bed.
Oscar bear, say, "Good night, Jimmy."
-Yay! Buddy, hi!
-Say, "Good night, Jimmy." Say, "Good night, Jimmy."
-Good night, good night.
-Say, "Good night." [ Laughs ]
Thank you. -He's so cute.
-No, he's not saying, "Good night."
He wasn't happy with his dinner.
-[ Laughs ] He wasn't -- Yeah. Of course not. Yeah.
Look at his dad. Of course, yeah.
You shouldn't serve him, like, eight courses, yeah.
-Bad. -Guys, it is time for
"Gordon Ramsay Settles It."
Here we go.
-♪ Gordon Ramsay Settles It ♪
♪ Gordon Ramsay Settles It ♪
-Alright, buddy. First one.
Does fruit -- Does fruit count as a real dessert?
-Of course it [bleep] doesn't.
[ Laughter ]
-You can't -- -Come on, man.
-You can't say that. You can't say that.
-[Bleep]. Sorry. No, it doesn't.
-Of course it doesn't. Yeah. Thank you.
-Thank you. -Two, should you cut the crust
off a peanut-butter and jelly sandwich?
-No! Stop being a snob. The crust are good.
[ Applause ]
-Yeah, but on a white bread -- on white bread
with peanut-butter and jelly,
I don't think you need the crust.
-No. Man, you've changed. -Oh, my g--
Ha. Alright.
Number three, Sriracha or Frank's Red Hot?
-Definitely Sriracha. -Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I feel like it's like a roller coaster for me.
Sometimes I love it, and then I'm, like, tired of it.
Alright. Here we go.
Ketchup with eggs: janky or swanky?
-Definitely swanky...
-I totally agree with you! It is totally swanky!
[ Laughs ]
Leftover pizza -- eat it cold or reheat it?
-Get it in the [bleep] trash.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on, dude. Don't do that to me, man.
-Come on. -Don't do that to me, man.
Red-wine teeth or white-wine breath?
[ Laughter ]
-There is nothing worse than smelly breath.
-I totally agree with you.
-So I'm gonna go for red-wine teeth.
-Yes. I agree with you. Yes. Thank you.
-Yes.
-Nothing worse than white-wine breath.
That is just rancid and weird. Oh, this is interesting.
Would you rather eat a brown banana or a brown avocado?
-A brown [bleep] banana. Seriously?
-Banana, yeah. Absolutely. Yeah, exactly, yeah.
Ew. Yeah. A brown avocado -- -I'll go for the avocado.
-Alright, yeah, I'm sorry. Good.
What's worse to get on Halloween:
Necco wafers or raisins?
-Give them back to them.
[ Laughter ]
-Give the candy back to the people.
-Yes. Raisins?
-That's so -- That's such a Gordon Ramsay thing to do.
It's like, "Yeah, I know that Ramsay kid.
He gave the candy back to us."
[ Laughter ]
Truffle oil: secret weapon or dish destroyer?
-A dish destroyer! -I totally --
-Should be [bleep] banned.
-A restaurant destroyer.
Potato chips on a sandwich?
-Absolutely. -Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright. Last one.
Gordon Ramsay, should ranch dressing be used
on anything besides salad?
[ Audience saying "yes" ]
-Absolutely not.
-Thank you! Yes! That's why we're buddies!
That's what I'm talking about! You heard it here first!
My thanks to Gordon Ramsay!